[Music]
the stakes are very high for newly
elected South Korean president named JM
he faces the dangers of Kim jong-un of
North Korea who had to increase the pace
his missile and nuclear tests and is
seeking to show us in the United States
that he could put a nuclear warhead on a
missile capable of hitting our homeland
that's not just a threat to us it's a
threat to the entirety of the alliance
system in Northeast Asia we've been
working closely with our allies in Japan
and South Korea an increased defense
cooperation we need strong allies
working together but Japan and Korea
have had difficulties in the past
however given the sobering nature of the
threat moon has indicated he will
continue with this defense cooperation
even if cautiously he is walking into a
new policy by the competent ministration
that's seeking to put maximum pressure
on North Korea and on China to isolate
the Hermit Kingdom it cannot succeed
though if the Korean president puts
brakes on this campaign giving the
sobering nature of Kim's danger I think
moon will continue with the tougher
policies of his predecessor and learn
more about my take on u.s. North Korea
policy click the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you want a AEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds